[Music]
when i'm dancing
it makes me feel like i'm flying
it feels like
i'm free
and
it's the best feeling
i started dancing when i was seven years
old
and
i didn't know
that i wasn't want to be a dancer but
this was inside of me
and was so easy
it was like my body was ready to do that
i just realized that i want to keep
doing this
for life
[Music]
when i was a kid i was the only black
dancer in the studio with more than 50
white ballerinas
when you think ballet
you think about white people dancing
i heard that i was never gonna make in a
classical company because i was a black
ballerina
how you say to someone that you're not
gonna make your drinks and i never stop
to fight and i'm here now
[Music]
freedom
came when i moved to london
and i can see
that i could be a black ballerina i can
dance with white dancers black dancers
and it's just amazing
[Music]
when i'm improvising it's kind of
my style of dance
is a mix of what i learned as a
classical
as a contemporary dance what is the way
i move my body
it's not really choreographed i do love
it against the big classicals and
everybody look the same same arms
this is like a
technical
but i do love to have this freedom as
well that i can move as me
is the movement
is the music
is part of freedom
that you connect with your with your own
body
[Music]
it's been a long journey and
i love
how far
and how beautiful become
inside the street you have all types of
bodies all types of dancers
and colors we are mixed
and we only have one single language and
it's dance
we celebrate freedom
we're celebrating diversity equality
in one studio and i wish
wasn't just inside the studio was like
in the whole world
[Music]
i have to say believe
and it's like a note to
i wake up or when i'm on a train or
somewhere and i look you say you always
have to believe
that you're gonna get there
to never forget
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video